ah yes Christmas started yay dude she
put up a [ __ ] Christmas tree no
whoops scratch that she put a [ __ ]
two Christmas trees up already and it's
right now the way we're recording this
it is October uh it is October uh 14th
it's just like uh it's too much so my
house is kind of softly it's got like
this it's softly being decorated for
Christmas so far
it's it's a soft we're having the
Christmas soft opening
October 12th
uh and you can see Christmas trees in
our I wonder what our [ __ ] neighbors
think just like driving by seeing
Christmas trees in our they're like are
you serious it's October like we're the
house that people are are yeah they're
they're having conversations with their
own friends that we don't know them and
they're like yeah there's a house on our
street already that's got two Christmas
trees up in the windows and then someone
else is going seriously about my family
that I don't know
so that's where I'm at in this life
in this lifestyle
yeah you say in this lifestyle insane
[Music]
um
yeah she's into this uh lady well I
should play some of this stuff
um
she's into this lady
that decorates for Christmas she's like
this lady is my favorite Christmas
decorator and her name is Rebecca
Robeson
and she's like watch a little of this
with me and you know I'm a good guy
and so we play a little this woman like
her job is just decorating you know
which is a killer job if that's what you
love that's awesome like that's actually
awesome Christmas 201 home tour with
Rebecca Robson here we go
let me just
starts off like it's Black Adam
wow
the most Christmassy house Merry
Christmas here we go hi you guys there
you go and you know she's crazy just by
the tone and it's all good but she
popped in her own door like she was a
neighbor and said Merry Christmas guys
a lunatic but she's very styling I will
give her that and I bet she's a [ __ ]
really nice you can't really hate on
someone who loves Christmas you know
what I mean you just can't it's just so
positive and it's just a beautiful time
of the year you can't handle it and
these are all jokes this woman seems
like a you know a beautiful soul
but let's rip into her and you're here
at my channel to see the final reveal of
my home for Christmas this year look
what she's got a new home in Tulsa
Oklahoma wow
she lives in Tulsa well what do you do
there really
that's one of those places where we go
like it's actually got it but you know
you should come it's really growing into
it yeah yeah okay for this year
tones of course it is a flocked
Christmas tree naturally musical
instruments there you have it and
deer and why wouldn't there be care too
the theme that's all the Christmas [ __ ]
like this lady is acting like she
invented the wheel the theme this year
for Christmas is Dear Santa elves and
last but not least Christmas
yeah no [ __ ]
if you put these on the side of your car
four of them two on each side it will go
forward
the wheel
when I was planning out this Christmas
and trying to decide what to do in this
new home I was going back to Nostalgia
things that what did I just say last
episode Dude that [ __ ] cold air peeks
up into under your shirt and it goes
like this with the Nostalgia
I can't do it because I'm iced out my
chains are in the way but
and the Nostalgia like there's like a
like a Daffy Duck cartoon
what's up with the Nostalgia and
Christmas it's because you had Christmas
when you were younger and that's when
life was simple and now it's a [ __ ]
you're you're you know you got PTSD and
you're eating black vitamins so um
yeah man this woman God she dresses like
my mom it's unbelievable I think the the
the the the the the the the more
fashionable and whiter and older lady is
the more she dresses like [ __ ] The
Last Airbender
my mom's got those big sleeves man and
my mom's butting the [ __ ] up with those
[ __ ] those buttons that have like the
loop and then that like
thing that hooks into the loop oh dude
if you're a white lady and you don't
have buttons with a loop and another
[ __ ] tassel that Hoops into the loop
man you might have some other race in
you and Asians and white like Asians in
academies and then
older white ladies dude forget it man
big ass with like like straw kind of
like looking straw like burlap [ __ ]
you know shoes with no laces oh [ __ ]
that somewhere your your your your name
is either ping toy or Ethel you know
what I'm talking about
so racist uh but whatever I'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] on whites too we shot on them
all
we [ __ ] on them all what can we do
um
so yeah dude Rebecca rubs and check her
stuff out she's great she'll get you in
the Christmas the comments I love
they're so positive is positive like
these people will never have hater shits
like you go on my comments and it's like
why is this [ __ ] Mr Burns bird-like
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] talking about this
he doesn't know anything
and from for the then the this it's like
oh Rebecca with exclamation points like
oh like who starts a [ __ ] YouTube
comment with oh like it's like like it's
like an Elation oh Rebecca you've done
it again I love your Christmas videos I
uh hard to name my favorite seriously
and and you and you might be like oh
well this this this must be like a
comment that's like from a company like
a candle company that's like a mom and
pop shop and it's just from heel tap
ziggum
and you're like oh just a real person is
just enjoying the [ __ ] out of this
YouTube video
like how is that even a real
here look Amy Copeland you put so much
thought and heart into your designs love
being a follower for several years now
Merry Christmas to you and your family I
love this this is just the best of the
internet
[Music]
[Music]